go rest but at a bar ah welcome back to
another episode about lesson I did not
cheat on your girlfriend cheap cheated
there was a mam don't take me [ __ ]
priests good aren't you
no yeah he's a witness or whatever you
must be exhausted
nope let's take over huh buddy you'll do
a martini lunch
man you look a what if that [ __ ] is he
gonna do with me Oh Russ I don't want
you to lose my dick I'm not ready for
that he doesn't even have a name
Martha Stewart it's not a good name for
my dick I don't know why I even thought
about that that's really inappropriate
love them watch it go ahead all day here
No all right now but the pedestrians but
but I want to go but but but but but but
I wanted I wanted to go there has to be
it away don't know no play place I
didn't do anything I didn't know you it
was your elevator please
the naked guys run out to me you know Oh
Todd
Jason use anyway really told I was just
trying to let you know what I don't I
don't want to go in here but I really
don't want to be in here
thanks so much for coming by
we'll begin your consultation
dead don't cut off my dick oh hey I
don't stay away from my porn give us a
chance to talk Oh Jase nice eyes
damn am I supposed to escape now letting
him confuse you with all these
holier-than-thou Bible something
what do you know what you do with agile
you need to cut your nails not to my
face okay I work with concrete you have
to run a night when all these cool
[Music]
[Applause]
that is some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I would have to just shut the little
more before if you know what I mean are
you [ __ ] serious that's all you had
to do seriously stop okay why do you
insist on bringing the camera bring the
wheelchair I gotta take a leak
getting okay oh I'm just now I'm
bringing this broom up his eggs where is
he what
nothing that he's still alive
service learning is like that what they
were well Charlotte you can't can solve
it nobody nobody no I stopped pumping
there oh it's just a huge
misunderstanding I'm a bad I swear to
God on my bed I didn't have anything to
do with anyone I did somebody better
just gonna go out here oh [ __ ] well read
this great oh no no no no no no no what
are you I'm a bad I'm a bad I'm a bad I
swear to God
ah son of a [ __ ] you sold me out oh oh
oh that's not good that's a stop Jack
dickbag god damn it going for it exit oh
[ __ ]
later Oh only close one of them run
[ __ ] what you gonna do about combo just
click oh it's a key why does it always
okay don't panic don't panic don't panic
don't panic don't panic don't panic just
go up there it's gonna be fine
shut up ah I don't know how much shot my
heart can go on every night in my dreams
I see peeve nothing okay what's a month
into this edit that I'm pissed yeah what
oh great
Oh
hey how you doing say whatever you're
you oh thanks thanks thanks for selling
me out oh [ __ ] oh come on
ah Jase you [ __ ] up now pants but
nobody likes a guy with a [ __ ] huge
ass severe where where is the king it
has to be somewhere have you been in
here I do believe not okay we're good in
the hood let's just find the key and get
the [ __ ] out of my dock March eternal
Emmet Quran okay the key has better
[ __ ] bid don't you dad what did I
just [ __ ] say hi jeez
all right here we go
[Music]
why does he hate me don't you yellow
[ __ ] idiot I hate you I'm cool okay
the key has to be here yes of course
quite isn't this where I came from
[Music]
so far nothing has worked out whether in
this game we're just gonna have to go
for it
are you ready for me Bros on three one
sorry I'm sorry I couldn't wait okay Oh
jab naughty kittens rub sake you are not
allowed [ __ ]
[Music]
hide in a urinal they said it will be
fun yourself yes I said oh we're so dead
I don't like it I don't like when he
does side - sound oh I'm just taking a
poopoo
I'm just taking a poopoo never take a
bow I just take it aborts please
let's see it's not here is it love it I
thought are you [ __ ] kidding me are
you [ __ ] kidding me
are you I'm not ok with this what do I
do I don't know why but that [ __ ] Chi
took me [ __ ] forever to find
hopefully of course of coop course of
course why would I have it this way yeah
[ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] this floor I'm going to Hawaii
oh not today sir not today I may not be
a fighter but I hate scissors that
[ __ ] day oh not to Allah that's what
happens if you don't have hair I think
well if you could have just [ __ ] kill
them right away that would have helped
I'm not okay I'm not okay Jesus
I want to break like a break like I'm
gonna oh what's up here
that door is locked
jogging down the stairs jogging down the
stairs minding my own business I'm
jogging down the stairs why don't I just
jump up I can't they are locked
[ __ ] all right let's go in here I'm just
I'm just I'm a very poor much very
gentle soul at the moment I would wish
that first there was a [ __ ] guy then
there was the non buff mean guy and now
I just want some peace I would like some
tea I'm in UK survived
what is he heard that secular maniac
would carve you up like the others I
don't like you meet me outside we're
closed down outside cool that sounds
[ __ ] great
[ __ ] him I'm going out I just don't
really trust this place
ha
please please be nice be nice okay be
nice be nice day I just I just I just
did this don't don't kill me please that
would be great
don't don't do anything mean to me I
don't know what outside is may be here
oh oh sure sure I'm gonna have to ends
up son here hope you had fun watching
wait like if you're dead and have some
cat a lot
let's subscribe to become a bread today
I'll see in the next one there's a
brother's play